you're listening to the real estate talk
show
with simon janini and aaron mccoy on
talk radio am 640.
welcome back to the real estate talk
show here on talk radio am 640 your
source for all things real estate now
it's time
for interview with an expert now this
segment is brought to you by enbridge in
their new home rating program
giving realtors and their clients a
competitive advantage when selling a
home
to find out how you can benefit as a
homeowner or realtor visit
knowyourenergyscore.ca today
you have probably watched the tv shows
shark tank and cbc's dragon's den now in
its seventh season and one of the more
controversial dragons on the show
is also a very savvy investor of course
i'm talking about kevin o'leary
a canadian entrepreneur venture
capitalist and television personality
kevin welcome to the show thank you
aaron great to be here great to have you
we've been looking forward to a little
more attitude so
we trust you you won't disappoint hey
listen you know i'm just an investor
trying to scrape out a living
yeah no i like that so listen i have to
ask you because you're a busy guy and
you're involved in so many different
ventures
what motivated you to get into the
mortgage business what possessed you
to get into the mortgage business you
know i look at sectors
as investors you've pointed out and i
look at the long-term probability of
them so
the good analogy for me would be back in
2007
2008 when the markets were in a
disastrous turmoil
and i got into the mutual fund business
i like to get into
sectors when everybody hates them and
right now you can't find a more hated
sector than mortgages because
everybody's making the assumption
real estate's going to go flatter down
rates are going up it's a disaster out
there no one's making any money in the
mortgage business i love all that stuff
i love chaos i like to enter during
periods of chaos and build value from
there and i look back now
at o'leary funds our mortgage business
which has a billion dollars in it in
only a short four years so i'm pretty
happy with that outcome
now o'leary mortgages uses the term the
honest mortgage can you explain that
let's just think about what a mortgage
is in a person's life and this is you
know i discuss this a lot in the books i
write and when i teach kids in school
going into debt in this size because
usually the mortgage is the largest
commitment people are making in their
lives they're buying their home
they're in for hundreds of thousands of
dollars in most cases and this is what i
find remarkable they have no plan on how
to manage that debt they go into it not
knowing how they're going to pay it back
and when you do that you're being
dishonest with yourself
you're getting into a commitment that
could ruin you if you don't manage it
properly put you in a
horrible place down the road over commit
you to things you can't actually support
and you're not being honest with
yourself so i look at it this way saying
look
i want to sell you a mortgage but i want
you to understand what the commitment is
you're making and by the time you get
educated through my process at leary
mortgages
you may do a lot of things differently
and will both be in a better place
because
i want you to buy products and services
at prices you can afford not just today
but for the next seven years
so kevin is part of that process helping
the borrowers
to understand how to pay that debt down
faster because the banks
they're not in the business to help you
pay off your mortgage faster and they'll
typically offer you
extended amortizations is that something
you're going to do a little differently
no of course i mean i don't have the
same incentives the bank has
i'm trying to help you as someone who's
going into debt to manage the process
i'm much better off if you understand
what you're getting yourself into
and you know how you're going to get out
of it so things that i focus on are what
is going to be the duration what's the
amortization schedule how much you
actually going to debt for
what are the attributes or the features
of the mortgage that allow you to
accelerate paying off the principal if
you wanted to
these are many questions people never
ask i obviously have
with a brand like o'leary people come to
me for things like mortgages and mutual
funds
and then what i want to do is work with
them and a lot of this can be done
online now which i'm really excited
about to help you make your decision
from all the various lenders including
me
i may not be the right person to
actually fund your mortgage there may be
somebody else
at least going through me is going to
force you through a process that i think
is going to make you a better borrower
kevin all of your mortgages have a
feature that you have trademarked called
secure rate can you tell us more i'm a
huge advocate
for fixed income right now or in terms
of a fixed rate
so that you know going in that there's
not going to be a change in your
monthly cost what we had was so popular
for so long as rates were coming down
is a variable rate mortgage i offer
those but i don't advocate them
what i'm saying to people is at the very
least
lock in your rate now for five years if
you're in a variable rate mortgage
switch out of it and lock in your rate
when you lock in a rate for five
years you're guaranteeing yourself what
your nut is every month and that's so
important
i'm guessing that the reason you're not
really promoting variable rates right
now is because of current market
conditions obviously that commentary
would change if things
were different in two or three or five
years from now well i'm worried about
the volatility in the rate markets
because i've lived through three
interest rate
cycles and so what i can't provide you
with
is a forecast of what your servicing
costs are going to be if you have a
variable rate mortgage
the old bank would say to you listen
don't worry about it variable rate
mortgages is only scary if we have a
massive rate increase well we've gone
through those
what i'm scared about is having just a
two percent increase on people that have
borrowed too much
that puts them over the top and in my
estimates that's as many as 38
of the market right now and they're just
making the assumptions rates stay low
forever they're gonna be in real trouble
if rates go up two percent with rates
where they are especially with the five
seven even some of the 10-year rates
it's hard to argue that would be the
good bet these days i go back and i'm
you know i'm a student of history
the 40-year average of the 10-year note
in canada was 6.2 percent
mortgages were priced above that at some
point in our lifetimes we'll get back
there because that's the mean that's the
average that's the
long-term number you're talking about
mortgage rates around seven percent in
that situation in the best case
nobody's talking seven percent anymore
everybody's making the assumption
they're going to get their mortgage
between three and four percent long-term
that is probably not going to be the
case so that's why i'm saying to people
now if you're take buying your first
condominium or your first home lock that
thing in at around three percent that's
probably what you can get and for the
next five years you know that
with certainty you're paying three
percent when that five years is over i
think it's gonna be a whole different
ballgame
so shy away from the uncertainty now
your in-house mortgage products are
called the honest mortgage value
mortgage and you also have entrepreneur
mortgage can you also explain that
further
an entrepreneur mortgage is to somebody
who's not insurable and that generally
those are people that have started their
own business
aren't working for somebody else when
they go to get an insured mortgage from
a bank they're
obviously rejected and they're put in a
different situation
and so there's a whole different market
that lends to those people
and that's what i'm trying to help them
with because there's all kinds of
options some of which are very expensive
some are not
i'm a good resource in terms of helping
people decide which way they're going to
solve that problem
if you're an entrepreneur and you have a
business and it's growing or it's stable
and you're paying yourself from it i
should be able to get you a mortgage
it's just not going to be as cheap as an
insured one and it may want to have some
attributes
that are more flexible for you
particularly in your ability
to pay down the principal because what
happens entrepreneurs sometimes is they
are very successful
and they want to be in a product where
they can just eradicate the debt
a lot sooner than they were planning we
know that more and more entrepreneurs
are coming in the marketplace it's a
trend that's not going to change it's
actually increasing yet there has been
no product or a real effort to fill that
need it's refreshing to see that you're
actually trying to do something about
this
well one of the problems is it's been a
perfect storm balance sheets on banks
have been asked to deliver for the last
you know since 2008 when we put all
these new restrictions on banks we're
not even finished doing it so
you can't really fault their behavior
where they used to be far more
aggressive in providing
debt of all kinds to entrepreneurs
they've shied away from that now the
truth is a small cap or mid-cap business
in canada can't usually get a loan
anymore from a bank i mean
they don't tell you that i'm telling you
that yeah and so they have to go to the
alternate credit markets and they have
also dried up because
investors are far more conservative what
happens in the case
of a very viable entrepreneurs and that
wants to buy a home
it requires a fair amount of due
diligence in other words understanding
exactly what their
his or her circumstance is and then
matching it to either one of our funds
or
another lender that's interested in
providing a source of equity to them
it's challenging from that perspective
because banks used to embrace this and
have teams
that would work on it and they've all
stopped doing it so you're right this is
a really difficult market
i've never seen it as dry as it is today
and yet there are lenders and some of
them are from the united states that
provide funds to canadian equities
believe it or not
we have to look at all these
alternatives you know you hit on it
earlier it's going to cost
more there's no question about it
because the companies that provide it
have to do a lot more work in the
background
i see a huge opportunity in the
marketplace and you're right sometimes
when you do see chaos you do see
opportunities i see you
getting some great success with this any
final points you want to tell our
listeners about all your mortgages
i just think that the lesson is it's
worth coming and looking at
elainemortgages.com just to learn
from it because we've approached this in
a completely different way
you know i talk a lot about in the two
books i've written cold hard truth in
men women and money there's a whole
section on mortgages and i'm writing my
third right now called love and money
you know the more i meet young people
the more i realize
the mortgage is probably the tipping
point in their life
it's a time of great joy because it's
the first portion of real substantive
ownership
but in many many cases i find it to be
very traumatic later because they just
didn't do it right
and they got themselves in huge trouble
part of the calculator of
getting into debt is what can i really
afford
and often what i find just in final
thoughts is
that home you wanted to buy you should
have bought something 20
smaller that's really if it's your first
home your first condo
downsize your optimism a little bit
about your situation so that you don't
borrow too much
i've met thousands of people and so this
is a consistent message i give all of
them now
you've got to be very careful about how
much commitment you make to a mortgage
and it's from a guy that's selling
mortgages
yeah well i like people that like to
shake it up and certainly make a
difference and boy oh boy kevin you're
certainly doing that
thank you very much i appreciate your
time yeah it's been great having you on
the show
thank you thanks kevin for taking the
time out of your very busy schedule and
we look forward to the next time and a
big thank you to our other guests
ruth valentine from real pro canada
daryl fursten from sage six condos and
build chairman steve upton of tridel
just a reminder that we cover a lot of
very important topics on the show and we
interview some of the top experts in the
business so you can get the inside scoop
on what's really going on
and we certainly hope you listen in
every week but if you ever miss a show
don't forget the recordings of all our
shows are available on our website at
real estate talk show dot ca
and if you haven't already done so
download your free copy of everything
real estate which is our 100-page guide
to buying and investing in real estate
and if you have any real estate
questions we want to hear it go to real
estate talk show
ca or call our help desk 416-366-9090
and we're also on twitter at
realtalkshow
that's it for our show this week be sure
to tune in every saturday at 6 pm
right here on talk radio am 6 40. until
next time have a great weekend everyone